هذه هي خفافيش الحائط ،
انظر إلى الغرفة هناك في الأعلى
والأسفل ،
هذه هي خفافيش بيرلاند ، أعتقد
أنها
لا تصدق ،
لذا فقد ذبلت
أشياء صغيرة جدًا على الأرض
لم تكن تبدو حية في ذلك الوقت على الإطلاق
الذي ذهبت إليه  سيارتي وأفرغت بعض
الصناديق التي تحتوي على أشياء
بداخلها وأدخلت بعض الأنسجة وأخذت الصندوق
إلى أسفل الجسر
وبدأت للتو في وضع الخفافيش في الصندوق ،
لذا بمجرد أن يصابوا بالبرد يصابون
بصدمة منخفضة الحرارة وهم  لا يستطيعون الصمود
بعد الآن ، فإن أجسادهم تغلق حتى تنطلق
أقدامهم من حافة الجسر
أو تحت شق الجسر
ثم يسقطون لذا فهم جميعًا على ما يرام
كما
ترون وسيكونون مستعدين للإفراج  عندما
يكون الجو لطيفًا ودافئًا في بعض الأحيان ، كنت أحاول
أن أضع خفاشًا مثل الخفافيش الجديدة في
حاوية وتبدأ الخفافيش الموجودة
بالفعل في التحليق ، وبعد
ذلك سأطارد خفاشًا من خلال العلية
كما تعلم ، لذا كان الأمر قليلاً  مجنون في
بعض الأحيان حسنًا ، نحن نعيش هنا في Wall
S.  treet Bridge ، أطلقنا سراح 600
خفاش
أجنبي
تعرف كثيرًا أنك تراهم في
الأفلام أو في نوع من القصص
وهم الشرير من نوع ما
ولكنهم أجمل الأشياء الصغيرة
وهم جدًا  لطيفة وغير
عدوانية وأعتقد أنها حيوانات رائعة